GUS CLASS: Hello, and welcome
to the Google+ developer
office hours.
I'm Gus Class, a developer
advocate for the Google+
platform and I specialize in the
publisher features, such
as the +1 button, Share, and
now the history API.
Joining me is Jonathan.
He's on my team and is also
a developer advocate.
Jonathan, want to give
a little intro?
JONATHAN BEYER: Hey everybody,
Jonathan Beyer here.
I'm the Google+ developer
advocate for Hangouts.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
So today, Jonathan will be
talking a little bit about the
Google+ Hangout apps.
And specifically, he'll be
talking about using the Google
Wallet API for payments
within Hangouts apps.
This is real exciting, because
it introduces a lot of new
scenarios for people who are
interested in accepting
payments from Hangouts.
So Jonathan, want to
get going with it?
JONATHAN BEYER: Yeah, sure.
So for those who don't know
about the Google commerce APIs
and specifically payments,
Google provides a really easy
to use e-commerce API to allow
you to accept payments inside
your web apps.
And it's competitively
priced [INAUDIBLE]
industry.
But the key thing about it is
it's really easy to use.
And by really easy to use, I
mean I had no idea how to use
it, and I got it working
within an afternoon.
I actually just used the public
documentation, and I
was able to accept payments
within my Hangout app, which
is really awesome.
So I'm going to start with
screen shares to walk you
through a few things.
Switch over.
Now, you should be
seeing my screen.
Is that--
Gus, can you see it?
GUS CLASS: Yeah, I can see it.
Also Jonathan, I want to remind
anyone who's watching
to ask any questions you have
within the event, and we'll
try to get to them
as we go along.
JONATHAN BEYER: Great.
So the homepage for the
Google Wallet is
developers.google.com/commerce.
And there's the Digital Goods
API which was formerly known
as the In-app Payments API, and
that allows you to accept
payments within your
application.
Now, all it really requires you
do is to learn a little
bit of technology which I'll go
over in a bit, and a simple
JavaScript API.
The piece that you've got to
learn is a thing called JWT.
It's an acronym for JSON Web
Tokens, and it's just an
encryption algorithm for
transporting secure
JSON over the wire.
The fortunate thing is there's
an array of libraries in
pretty much every programming
language out there, so it was
really easy for me to
get up and running.
And using a sample application
that came with the developer
site that's hosted there, I
was able to integrate that
pretty quickly.
So let me talk a short, brief
minute about what JSON Web
Tokens are by going through
the documentation.
And as it loads--
so a JSON Web Token is really
an encrypted JSON file.
And the pieces to the JSON Web
Token are some timestamp
information like when it's
issued, an expiration date,
and then the actual items
you are trying to sell.
What makes it a token or
encrypted is your seller ID
and the seller secret that
Google gives to you.
And then the library that you
choose use wraps it up, and
then you call a simple
JavaScript API.
And on this page you'll see
the actual method is
[? payment.in-app.buy ?].
[? And ?]
you pass in the JWT and you
start the purchase flow.
It's really that easy.
Now what I wanted to do,
switching back to camera, I
want to make a very simple
application that allows me to
buy something inside
of a Hangout.
So to simplify--
[INAUDIBLE I wrote a simple App
Engine project based off
of the sample project
that whittles it
down to an AJAX service.
And I'm going to walk you
through the AJAX service.
But the neat thing about the
AJAX service is, I just pass
in the name, description, the
price in the URL to that AJAX
request and it creates
a purchase.
This is really good for
debugging and testing.
Probably not something you want
to use in production.
So switching to the
actual code.
Can you see that OK, Gus?
GUS CLASS: Jonathan, you may
want to make the font a little
bit bigger for the people
looking because it's--
I'm having trouble actually
maximizing this video for the
full screen.
JONATHAN BEYER: How about now?
Is it--
GUS CLASS: It looks
lot better for me.
JONATHAN BEYER: OK, great.
So for anybody who's
not used Python!
With App Engine before,
this is a Python!
project, it is very simple.
The two things that you'll
notice at the top is we
importing the JWT library and
we're also importing from the
seller info file, my seller
ID and seller secret.
I'm not going to show that to
you, because then people can
start taking making
money for me.
But there's a URL that we'll
have in the show notes that
helps you generate your own
seller ID and seller secret.
But outside of that, the
process is really easy.
I have this route, this AJAX
JWT route, that creates a
timestamp, assigns some default
values for the name,
price, and description, and then
encodes that information
into a JSON Web Token.
And you can see, it's just
standard JSON with my seller
secret which tokenizes it.
And then, I do a
[? response.out.right ?]
basically returning that JSON
Web Token to the AJAX request.
A minor nit here, I'm
adding CORS headers.
That allows me to do cross
domain requests in most modern
browsers, and it works
pretty reliably.
And that's in case you want to
do something like a gadget
based Hangout app versus an
iframe based gadget app.
Anyway, those are little
addendums.
GUS CLASS: So Jonathan, to
clarify, so those CORS headers
are used specifically for this
scenario because you're using
cross domain scripting
on here?
JONATHAN BEYER: Exactly.
We have a sample application
that shows you how to serve
your hang-up from
your own iframe.
If you do that, if you want to
do AJAX from the same domain
to same domain, works
no problem
even in legacy browsers.
If you're going to do something
like a cross domain,
in a pure JavaScript
environment, because it's
being hosted by Google,
different domain from where
your AJAX is being hosted.
GUS CLASS: So basically this
is AJAX being called from
within an iframe.
JONATHAN BEYER: Exactly.
GUS CLASS: Cool.
JONATHAN BEYER: I could have
not done this with AJAX, I
could have done as a pure
server-side application which
is probably the right way to
do it in many scenarios.
And this is just for
demonstration purposes and
flexibility.
GUS CLASS: Great, thanks.
JONATHAN BEYER: Now let's see.
What was the next thing
I wanted to show?
Yes.
So now actually using that,
let me switch back to the
screen share.
Switching back to the screen
share, I have our Hangout app.
This is a web app version, so
this will be iframe from my
app engine domain.
And for anybody's who's built
a Hangout app before, you'll
recognize the hangouts.js In the
iframe technique we have
to include an RPC library and
then we include the Google
JavaScript API library, that's
this one right here.
And that--
it'll be familiar if you things
like maps and other
APIs that are JavaScript
based.
Then from here on out, actually
let me switch the
syntax over to make it
a little bit more--
ah, there we go.
From here on out, we're just
going to do a basic XHR
request, pass in the name
description and price.
And here's where the actual
payment happens.
On the response to that
XHR I call the
goog.payments.inapp.buy.
And I pass in the data, which
is the JSON Web Token.
And any success or failure,
event handlers, they don't do
anything interesting
right now.
But when all is good, this will
start a purchase flow.
It happens in an iframe,
within my application.
As a developer, I don't have to
worry about anything that
happens here on out.
If there's a success,
there's a success.
If there's a failure,
there's a failure.
There's also a post back URL
that once the purchase
happens, I can do additional
logging.
The other thing that I skipped
over that's important to note
as well, is that if you're using
the Google payments API
for digital goods, you have
to load the library
with that JSON API.
And I do a google.load.
This is all documented in the
Getting Started Guide, but the
important thing to note here is
I'm actually running in a
sandbox config.
So when I'm running in the
sandbox config, it's a very
useful feature, because none
of the credit card
transactions will actually
really be charged.
So I can keep on testing,
tweaking, and doing more
development without actually
charging myself or doing $1.00
transactions which would be the
case if we didn't have the
sandbox environment.
And when you're ready to go to
production, you literally
change the package
to production.
And now you can accept
payments with
real credit card numbers.
GUS CLASS: Sorry, Jon.
JONATHAN BEYER: Oh,
no worries.
Now that we've actually seen
some of the code, I'm going to
try to see if I can do a screen
share of that simple
app that's actually
running today.
So let me screen share the
Hangout, this might have a
hollow mirrors effect.
I don't know yet.
Let's see.
Can you see the application?
GUS CLASS: Yes.
If you zoom in a little bit.
JONATHAN BEYER: Yeah, yeah.
So name, description, price.
Those are the parameters
that I was passing
into the AJAX request.
I'm selling a Slicer-Dicer which
is the best salsa maker
on the planet.
This AJAX purchase is going to
initiate the buy method.
And we'll see if that
successfully loads.
So now from here on out, the
developer doesn't have to
worry about anything.
This is the Google Wallet
doing its thing.
I have a test credit card.
So you don't even have to use
your own credit cards.
Google provides you with
an AmEx, MasterCard
and a Visa, I think.
So in sandbox, you can keep
on trying with that.
So it's completely, completely
sandboxed.
Go ahead and press Buy.
The flow continues.
Make sure that my Wi-Fi isn't.
And guess what?
The purchase has just
been successful.
And I'll probably see a success
method if I look in
the console.
I don't know if you can see the
console, but payment was
successful.
There's some weirdness going
on with the Hangout, so at
this point--
GUS CLASS: So Jonathan, to
clarify what's going on here,
you've got a sandbox account for
Google Wallet as well as
for the Hangout.
And so all of these transactions
that you are
doing are just nulls?
JONATHAN BEYER: Exactly,
exactly.
And so it actually gets recorded
in the sandbox log,
so you can see what's
being transpiring.
But there's no real money being
charged or any fees
being levied.
So you keep on testing
in sandbox.
And once you go to production,
you might want to have a bill
that is the production bill,
that takes currency and then
in your dev environment, keep
that sandbox built for
additional testing,
and purchases,
and things like that.
GUS CLASS: Cool.
So if you wanted other people
to test inside of your
sandbox, what would
they have to do?
Would you be able to share out
your app like you would any
others sandbox app and then--
JONATHAN BEYER: Exactly.
If I send this to you,
Gus, you can go ahead
and purchase that.
I'd recommend you using a
test credit card, but--
GUS CLASS: OK.
JONATHAN BEYER: --of course it's
in the sandbox, so even a
production one won't
be charged.
But as long as you have access
to my application,
you can test this.
So it's really neat for other
developers when they are
working together or if
you're doing Q&A.
GUS CLASS: Great, thanks.
JONATHAN BEYER: Yeah, I
think that covers it.
And you saw that code was
pretty straightforward.
The documentation was
super helpful.
We'll provide in the show notes
links to the sample
code, because we'll be
publishing this probably
tomorrow morning with the
App Engine project.
[INAUDIBLE] credit cards, how to
get your cell information,
and of course, the commerce
application, the digital goods
application is already up, and a
link to all that afterwards.
GUS CLASS: Great.
So what we are seeing is a real
simple example of how to
use Google Wallet APIs from
within a Hangout app.
And so Jonathan, we'll make sure
that we include the link
to the sample code with the
video so that people can
download it, play with
it, experiment.
And then we'll have a little
starter project for other
developers out there.
JONATHAN BEYER: Thank you.
GUS CLASS: So I guess what would
be interesting now would
be if anyone has any questions,
make sure that you
ask them in the event, and
we're monitoring that.
And so Allen just asked, are
there any best practices for
determining what products a
person has purchased to make
them available in
Hangout apps?
JONATHAN BEYER: So let me think
more about that question.
There's a--
I skipped over the JWT pretty
quickly, but let's see if I
can go back to it.
There's is a section in that JWT
that's called seller data.
GUS CLASS: So could
you move that--
can you actually expand
it a little bit more?
We're having trouble
seeing it.
JONATHAN BEYER: Let me
know if this is good.
Looks good?
GUS CLASS: Maybe a little
bit bigger?
JONATHAN BEYER: OK.
It's not very interesting what
I'm trying to show you, but
there's a field called
seller data.
And that's one of the attributes
on the JSON that
gets encoded in the JWT.
And that's where you want to put
some additional tracking
information.
So if you are trying to figure
out what part of your
application it's being come
from, let's say you have
different applications, both in
a Hangout and on the web,
you'd probably want to stick
that in there so that purchase
gets tied to whatever that
metadata is there.
In terms of figuring out what to
sell, you probably want to
think about creating your own
recommendation engine.
There are, of course, plenty
of e-commerce solutions for
recommending products.
Your mileage may vary, I know
a bunch that I could
recommend, because I've worked
with a lot of them.
But to figure out what to sell
is going to become the bread
and butter of your application
engine.
GUS CLASS: Thanks, Jonathan.
So also, what are the
types of scenarios
that we really expect?
Or what are people really been
excited about doing with
in-app payments?
JONATHAN BEYER: That's
a great question.
So the traditional I'm buying
something within an
application makes sense.
Think about games, power-ups,
levels, customization for your
characters.
Those are pretty obvious.
If you think of buying new
games within games.
So if you have casual games like
checkers or chess, and if
you want to buy a Chinese
backgammon or something like
that, that's also totally within
the realms of what
in-app payments do.
But other scenarios which are
pretty interesting, if you
want to do something like a
freemium model where you can
provide a level of
your service.
So if it's not even a game,
let's say it's for an activity
app and you want to say oh, one
gig of storage is free.
Additional storage you can use
in-app payments to buy that as
a one time fee.
But the other piece that we
didn't go over is the
introduction of subscription
billing.
So I believe at Google I/O, we
announced the ability to do
subscription-based billing.
So if you're doing a service,
maybe you're doing a
subscription for lessons
inside of a Hangout.
So something like a cooking
class or education where they
load the application.
Before they can start, you
check whether they have a
subscription.
Otherwise you do some sort
of prompt to subscribe.
That's really interesting and I
think people will definitely
start exploring that as
soon as they can.
GUS CLASS: Cool, that's
pretty exciting.
I guess another question would
be-- so we talked a little bit
about best practices.
What about security
considerations?
How do we know that the
information that's being
shared within the Hangout
because it's a JavaScript app
in an iframe, right?
How do we know that the various
credentials are secure?
And what are some of the key
security measures that are
being demonstrated
in this sample?
JONATHAN BEYER: That's also
a great question.
The JSON Web Token is core to
what's making in-app payments,
or digital goods
rather, secure.
Because it is using a seller
secret and hashing that JSON,
it's hard to decrypt it.
There's also time stamps within
the JSON Web Token, so
when it was created and when it
expires which is persistent
on the server side, so it
validates that as well by
making it moot if somebody tries
to figure it out after
it's expired.
And the communications
is done over HTTPS.
So even if you're using a
non-Hangout app and it's over
HTTP, the purchase is in an
iframe and it is secured.
So we do our best attempt to
making it a fool-proof system.
But you can rest assured that
there's all the industry
controls around making a
secure payment system.
We fall into those.
GUS CLASS: Great, thank
you, Jonathan.
Allen has a question.
And he's asking, in the
context of items to be
purchased and used inside
of the Hangout itself--
let's say that he has a game
inside a Hangout, what's the
best way to determine--
actually it looks like--
what's the best way to determine
what items they have
purchased, and then if they
want to use them in a game
later, what's the way to
synchronize across that?
What he suggested is using the
user's ID, storing it on the
server, and then using that to
look up which items they own,
and then bringing
it back later.
JONATHAN BEYER: You took the
words right out of my mouth.
GUS CLASS: OK, cool.
JONATHAN BEYER: In the context
of a Hangout, we've talked
about this in former Hangout
office hours, about there's a
Google+ ID, there's a Hangout
ID, and then there's the
participant ID.
They're all different,
they're all unique.
In the context of this, the most
absolute, unique way of
identifying the user on Google+
inside of a Hangout is
to use the Google+, their ID.
That's on the long URL when
you go to their profile.
Go ahead, use that as the key.
That's guaranteed and secure,
and we're not going to be
changing that.
So that's valid.
And App Engine has a great back
end for doing large types
of tables and big query
for big queries.
So if you have a huge
application, you can easy
troll through all those by
looking at the item ID
compared to a user ID.
That's the right way.
GUS CLASS: Cool, great.
Thanks for that suggestion.
And I guess we're--
I'm not seeing any questions
right now.
We'll hang out a little
bit longer.
Jonathan, if you could talk for
a moment about scenarios
other than games,
specifically--
people are interested in doing
things like accepting
donations through Hangouts.
And also about pay
per view content.
So, featured speakers
and so forth.
JONATHAN BEYER: Yeah.
So donations work the same
way as in-app payment.
We don't have a particular API
dedicated to donations.
But as you can imagine, because
our split with the
developers is so fair, it's
better than a lot of the
donation services out there.
So you would treat that as, I
want to donate $5 to this
cause, you would do that
with the digital goods.
In terms of non-game scenarios,
I think the
freemium model is the right
place to talk about this,
especially when you're talking
about productivity software.
So if I have one user in the
system, or five users in the
system that's free, if it's
a combine board, or a
[? sprint ?] planning board, and
if I add additional users,
I have to buy additional
seats.
You can do that as a one-time
purchase, or you can do that
as recurring billing.
And then if you want to
piecemeal your product, so I
have something where you can use
just the [? sprintboard ?]
for free, but if you want to
have real time chat with
logging, you have to pay an
additional $100 a year, or
something like that.
That's also a great scenario
to do that.
I think the premium content
is very interesting, and I
definitely like that model,
because you have full control
of the application that's
running in the Hangout.
And for somebody to do a
paywall, or subscription-based
content viewing, the app
lets you have full
control over that.
The digital goods make it
accessible and monetizable.
The one area that it gets tricky
is if you want to do
that over Hangouts on Air.
Because the Hangouts on Air is
not restricted to the app.
The Hangouts on Air can run on
youtube.com, it can run on
Google+ Stream, and it can run
anywhere you embed that
YouTube feed.
So if you're looking to control
streaming content or
even just static content on an
HOA setting, then you're going
to-- you can't use
digital goods.
Now, you can prevent
that functionality.
So within our API, you can
detect if somebody's
broadcasting, and that's
something that we'll be
exploring further to make
that even easier.
And then you could say hey,
you're broadcasting this
premium content.
We're going to stop the
feed until you stop
the Hangouts on Air.
And that's probably the best
solution for anybody who's
looking to do premium content
in a Hangout using digital
goods to monetize it.
GUS CLASS: Cool.
So another question
has come up.
What if you have a limited
set of products?
So let's say you've got a
special edition item, and
it'll be sold from within
a Hangout until
there's zero left.
You start with 10, and
it decrements.
Is this possible using the
Wallet API, or would you have
to use your own implementation
on the back end?
JONATHAN BEYER: So inventory
management is not done by
Google Wallet.
The payments API is the quick
and easy way to make
purchases, purchases
and subscriptions.
For doing inventory, you're
going to have to build
industry system or look towards
other systems that are
out there for inventory.
Your simple scenario, you
wouldn't need a full
e-commerce back end.
I worked with a bunch
of them in the past.
Sometimes they're overhead
that you don't need.
If you want to have 10 items
or X items and to decrement
them, I would do a simple
App Engine project.
Have one of our data store, or
even big query, depending on
what you're looking at, and then
use something like AJAX
to decrement each purchase.
It's actually a very easy code,
but the Wallet won't do
that for you.
GUS CLASS: So you won't get the
transaction APIs for that,
just from Wallet.
So there's another question, and
I really wish we had one
of the Wallet guys here, because
they'd totally be able
to cover this stuff.
But would you happen to know
what the limits are?
What's the minimum and maximum
for Wallet API payments?
JONATHAN BEYER: So
is that price?
Or is that--
GUS CLASS: Is it, I mean,
can you say--
I know that particularly in app
stores you will see the
minimum payment is like $1.
JONATHAN BEYER: Um hmm.
I don't know off the
top my head.
There is--
I can talk to you a little bit
about the pricing model
because we actually introduced
a new pricing model at I/O.
It's pretty favorable
for developers.
So when in-app payments launched
last year or so, we
had a flat 5% fee across
whatever your transaction was
which is very competitive
compared to other products,
which made it very desirable.
Recently, we introduced a
secondary structure which is,
I want to say, $0.30 plus 1.9%
off the total purchase.
And the beauty of--
GUS CLASS: Whoa, what
just happened?
JONATHAN BEYER: --as long as
it's a measurable amount.
But yeah, we'll have to follow
up with the Payments guys to
figure that one out.
GUS CLASS: Cool.
So it looks like we're not
seeing too many more
questions right now.
We'll wait a minute or two.
We had some minor technical
difficulties just recently
with the Hangout, but
we should be good.
JONATHAN BEYER: Well, Gus,
let me ask you question.
GUS CLASS: Yeah?
JONATHAN BEYER: You've
asked me so many.
What's the first use that
you want to see
with digital goods?
GUS CLASS: I mean, certainly
something that is really fun
is the notion of real
money within games.
I think it'd be interesting to
see things like actual item
purchases and other exciting
things for people who are
actually creating games.
I would really expect that to be
the first and most critical
use of payments within apps.
JONATHAN BEYER: Yeah,
definitely.
We have a strong user base of
developers who are interested
in games in Hangouts.
It's obvious why there's
a happy marriage there.
It's social, it's real
time, it's fun.
And I think we're going to see
a lot of adoption from the
games folks, bringing their
Hangout games, making it
monetizable.
GUS CLASS: I think it also is
going to mean more people
looking at that Hangouts API
and looking at Hangouts for
the kinds of games that
they can create.
JONATHAN BEYER: Yeah,
definitely.
And it's not just game
developers, it's not just
productivity and traditional
app developers that we'll
going to get interest from.
Brands, and marketing companies,
and agencies are
all saying, hey, this is a great
opportunity to build an
interactive art piece or web app
that brands can actually
get in front of the eyeballs
of their consumers.
And then of course, if you have
a monetizable piece to
that, that's awesome, right?
It's really hard to get ROI
in a marketing campaign.
But if you build a Hangout app,
which it's pretty easy to
do, make it fun and
compelling, people
could pony up for it.
GUS CLASS: Yep, and we've
definitely heard some success
stories about charities with
getting really good engagement
from within Hangouts.
And maybe supporting a donation
model within their
Hangout apps and stuff could
give them direct revenue from
within apps.
So that's a cool scenario
for sure.
JONATHAN BEYER: Yeah,
definitely.
And there's a lot of traditional
Hangouts that are
high-profile, low-profile,
crazy things going on in
Hangouts that can be enhanced
with use of Hangout apps.
What was the one
I saw recently?
There was LA Robotics Club
was doing a hack-a-thon
just the other day.
Maybe the thing's still going
on today, and people were
building together and hacking
and building crazy robots.
But now imagine if you could
somehow turn that around and
do a hack for good kind
of experience.
It's not necessarily a
application or a game that you
engage with, but maybe you
donate to a particular team so
that they can get more stuff.
And part of that revenue
goes to a foundation.
Or whoever wins gets a pot and,
the remainder goes to the
foundation.
So this is not a web app, this
is not a game, but this is
using Hangouts to connect people
and also the digital
goods to bring monetization
opportunities.
GUS CLASS: Great, so looks
like the conversation has
quieted down a bit.
And I think we're about ready
to wrap up, Jonathan.
Thanks, everyone,
for watching.
It's been a fun Hangout today,
and keep an eye out for
Google+ office hours
in the future.
Jonathan, Anything
left to say?
JONATHAN BEYER: Just
thanks a lot.
If you have any questions about
Hangouts or Hangout
apps, or even digital
goods, feel free to
+Mention us on Google+.
And of course, we can connect
you if you have further
questions about the
commerce APIs.
GUS CLASS: Great.
Thanks, everyone.
Have a good week, and join us
again for office hours,
probably next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]